las gráficas de fx igualados raíz de x 1
- 1 cd x igual a x cuadrada + x / x y
hdx igual a la x se muestran a
continuación de ahí tienen ustedes las
gráficas muy bien aquí está la h la g y
la f bien nos dice selecciona y arrastra
tarjetas para crear una desigualdad
compuesta que ordene los valores de fx
gtx y hdx para valores de x cercanos a 0
pero no en 0 muy bien entonces fíjense
muy bien que queremos ver qué pasa cerca
de x igual a 0 y por ejemplo si nos
vamos al 1 vemos que h está por arriba
de g y que está por arriba de f de hecho
eso pasa para cualquier valor en esta en
esta gráfica verdad entonces lo que
podemos decir es que h es mayor o igual
que g que es mayor o igual que f
así que fx es menor o igual que
que es menor o igual que hdx y si lo
hice bien verdad efe menor kg menor o
igual que h perfecto a y está muy bien
entonces de esto se sigue que y aquí lo
único que nos piden es pues
esencialmente que sustituyamos las
funciones correspondientes veamos quién
era f
efe era 2 raíz de x + 1 - 1
y entonces efe es 2 raíz de x 1 menos
uno que es menor o igual que gdx ig x
era x cuadrada más x / x x cuadrada más
x / x y esto es menor o igual que la
otra que era la x verdad vemos que esto
era la x muy bien entonces esto
significa que pues esencialmente que los
límites se van a preservar entonces van
a preservar las desigualdades entonces
el límite de 2 raíz de x más uno menos
uno es menor o igual que el límite de x
cuadrada más x entre x que es menor o
igual que el límite
de la equis todo esto por supuesto
cuando x tiende a cero entonces aquí es
en donde viene realmente el teorema del
sándwich y nos dicen finalmente el valor
del límite cuando x tiende a 0 de x
cuadrada más x / x parece ser vamos a
ver en realidad tenemos que calcular el
límite cuando x tiende a 0 de esta
función que es 2 x 0 + 1 que es 1
entonces es 2 x 1 es 2 - 1 es 1 y esto
tiene que ser menor o igual que a a la x
cuando x tiende a 0 que es 1 así que
este límite es mayor o igual que 1 y
menor o igual que 1 así que quien podría
ser si no más que 1 verdad así que vamos
a ver qué es lo que pasa geométricamente
lo que está pasando es que hdx se
aproxima a uno cuando x tiende a cero y
la f también y como la g está en medio
pues justamente ahí está que que lo está
pasando verdad ahí está pasando ahí está
ocurriendo que tenemos nuestro sandwich
yenes
punto los límites coinciden ahora solo
para sentirnos bien vamos a comprobar
nuestra respuesta y ahí lo tienen lo
tenemos bien